More than 99% of the previously found animal species have now become extinct. Sometimes, it happens
Causing violent changes that wipe out most of the factions altogether
During a short period of time. So now we are reviewing the most incredible 5 mass extinctions
And a look at whether it is possible for the sixth to occur now.
Forty-four million years ago, the arthropods became extinct. During that period, most creatures were swimming
Or creep in shallow water. While the newly formed volcanic rocks were falling by water and wind
They interact with carbon dioxide and absorb it. As a result, CO 2 levels have dropped, and temperatures have dropped
And the water was submerged to form. Causing low ocean levels and shallow sea depletion
After several cycles of glaciation and shrinkage, about 86% of the flora
Lost forever.
Then over millions of years the oceans slowly began to thrive with fish and colonized the earth
Primitive plants eaten by creeping and flying insects.
Then 374 million years later, new plants contributed to the next mass extinction.
These plants absorbed enough carbon dioxide to create another cycle of global cooling. And changed the soil
The triggers of nutrient glutting in the ocean make up huge amounts of algae that are absorbed
Oxygen, resulting in the suffocation of more than half of the marine species. However and somewhere in this
The world, a small family of fish with fins like feet and lungs survived. Over
The next hundred million years, these creatures will evolve into amphibians
Reptiles and almost all modern wild animals.
About 250 million years ago, the Permian era began. It is the worst collective extinction in history
70% of wildlife and 95% of marine life have been wiped out
The billions of tons of volcanic gases destroyed the ozone layer and the average temperature of the oceans rose
Up to 40 ° C, it is hotter than most hot water basins. Acid rain fell all over
The planet, destroying life on earth.
Life took 50 million years to recover until the fourth mass extinction. And in
Meanwhile primitive small dinosaurs were scouring the earth. A huge volcanic rift broke out
In the middle of the planet. And separated the Americas from Europe and Africa, as a component
Atlantic Ocean. The volcanoes also emitted carbon dioxide, causing temperatures to rise about a dozen dead
80% of the objects at that time have been well done dinosaurs do well
In the new vacant land in the next 135 million years, it has grown to become
One of the largest wild animals that has ever lived in the world.
But everything has a good end. Many scientists believe that extinction
Dinosaurs were caused by the collision of a small-sized asteroid
On the Yucatan Peninsula in Mexico. The collision caused millions of tons of dust in the air
The sun shines and sets the end of all the huge dinosaurs (small ones
Survived evolved into birds). The world became ready for a small, rat-like creature
He is the grandfather of all modern mammals. During 50 million years, descended from his descendants
Wild animals, whales and horses we humans - varied and grew to dominate almost
On every environment on earth.
So where does this leave us now after 65 million years? Well, human dominance on earth
Which led to significant changes too, except for today's changes that occur over decades, not thousands of years.
Carbon dioxide levels have contributed to many past extinctions, and have risen at least
Only 25% in the past 50 years, which is a geologically short time. In addition to
Climate change, we have shown hundreds of species of overfishing, fishing, and the destruction of the citizen
And pollution. The extinction rates of the current factions are estimated
Between 100-1000 times higher than natural extinction rates
This is only if all groups threatened by population decline will actually be extinct
We may actually reach mass extinction in just a few years. Since the
Previous mass extinctions left some survivors, it is worth mentioning that
Creatures at the top of the food chain are usually the hardest hit. We may promise
The theater of history repeats itself, and allows a small unexpected object to replace us
To become the dominant form of life on the planet
Do you have curiosity about the finest animals that existed during these mass extinctions? See
The new video "5 crazy creatures we hope is still alive" Go to AsapTHOUGHT channel
We will explore some of the most brilliant and most absurd creatures throughout history
No longer with us. The link is in the description box for this video.
Subscribe for more weekly science sections!